he is a legend he is a hall of famer and
season two of straight up steve austin
premieres tonight at 11 p.m eastern on
usa network
the one the and only steve austin here
on the richison show how are you steve
i'm doing great rich i appreciate you
having me on to talk about the show
always
absolutely always uh did you spend any
of the uh you don't seem like a couch
potato to me
uh but did you spend any time of the
weekend watching some uh national
football league playoff action steve
man i can couch potato with the best of
them but
i've been out man just the weather i'm
in nevada the weather's been so good
i got on my side by side and i have been
four wheeling in the mountains
just about from daylight till dawn so
tell me what what is it what does a
weekend
in nevada look like for for stone cold
steve austin seriously walk me through
what you did
everybody wants to know oh you just uh i
load up my kawasaki krx 1000. i put it
on my trailer
i go meet a buddy uh and we just i got
all my meals packed up
yesterday we got in about 65 miles the
day before about 50 and
it's not just all hauling answers a lot
of crawling
stopping shooting the breeze and eating
eating lunches and stuff like that but
it's basically just exploring and
getting outside i mean
we've been inside enough yeah bad
quarantining
did you have you caught any old
highlights of any part of your life and
career
quarantining just flipping around the
channels running through something no
they seem to keep showing up on
uh twitter and you know other forms of
social media but
you know i never go back and revisit all
that stuff unless someone puts it out
there and there's been some
funny ones pop up but i don't look for
them like what's so not saying that you
look for him you just came across which
one funny one that popped up where you
just forgot about or you're like oh yeah
that was a great moment
anything like that goddang yeah there
was one
i think yes they call it the greatest
finish in the history of smackdown
it was the last two minutes about from
that roster about everybody
in the locker room that was there should
be in the hall of fame i will be in the
hall of fame soon
and everybody came out there and i think
there's probably eight to 12 guys
who rotated around hitting each other
with their finishes and of course
like dominoes the guys that got hit
needed to stay down they stayed down and
i i started it by taking the chokeslam
from the undertaker
and i finished it about two minutes
later with it by hitting the rock with
the stone cold stunner so
that one just made the rounds and they
call it the last the best two minutes
ever of a smackdown
and my my rich eisen show uh
expert on this tj jefferson you would
you were nodding your head as he was
beginning to walk through that whole
thing right oh yeah every everyone like
he said was just
finish after finish after finish but of
course it had to end with the goat
which is stone cold steve austin
[Laughter]
and you know the brains behind that was
pat patterson
and man for all those guys to feed in
and the sequence and the timing and no
you know
every you know blind feed was right
there where it needed to be
so it was executed at the highest level
possible
so when you say mastermind behind it
walk me through what what pat
what do you do i mean he just comes up
with it and talks to everybody about it
and things like that or what
yeah we lost pat a few months ago right
but pat was just one of those great
finish guys or just detailed guys in the
business just as far as
it'd be like orchestrating a game plan
or a final two minute drive to you know
win a game in football
he just said hey man here's what i see
and that's what we did
six-time wwf champion wwe
hall of famer from the class of 2009 and
the host of straight up steve austin
season two premiering tonight
on usa network stone called steve austin
right here on the rich eyes and show
farv as a guest huh you got brett on the
show this hey we went down to
mississippi and had a great time with
brett
did some outdoor activities uh then i
got
you know we're almost the same age rich
me and brett and so i was wondering how
this guy is going to be see what he's
going to be all about
and he was in there getting his makeup
on it was kind of a makeup preset with
me and brett and coleman and all that
other stuff
so but i was wondering how he's going to
be and i always introduce myself to the
guest before we start the show of course
and i i shook his head and i said god
dang brett's nice to meet you i said
i've been watching a long time
he looked up at me he goes i've been
watching you too stone cold
and we bonded from the moment we shook
hands until we parted ways
and he is he's an unbelievable guy to
spend us to spend the day with the
gunslinger
very cool yeah i got to tell you the
number of times where i've texted brett
and he always receives a text or a call
from me whenever something big is
happening in the nfl and he's always so
kind to call in
but sometimes he's he will always say
he's either
hunting fishing biking or playing golf
those are the like he's literally he
literally spends
probably more time outdoors than indoors
in his life
absolutely and to me i mean that's the
perfect schedule
would it be in that order though steve
wouldn't that be hunting fishing
biking golfing would that be your your
order
yeah for me you can take out the biking
and the
under the driving range so driving range
uh i'll put in
drinking a beer in place of this number
three
how far do you hit a golf ball i got to
hear that
how far can you hit a golf ball steve
which if i get a hold of one in the
proper fashion i'll send it into orbit
the problem is i rarely get a hold of
one square i'm either slicing them or
hooking them or topping them and
they'll go about 10 15 yards or
sometimes even that three footer
so it's pretty embarrassing but if i
connect it's gone
now when you say gone seriously what do
you mean give me give me a number give
me a number steve
i don't know i i i'll be 850 yards
well that would disintegrate the golf
ball steve i don't think
you're calling me a liar no i am not sir
no i am not but i'll i'll just take that
uh also you know that's the thing rich
when you look at the technique of those
golfers they're not the biggest human
beings in the world
right and a lot of them are like
ectomorphic and milk some not
but man with that technique you can be
as strong or as powerful as you want to
be but
it's all about the technique i know i
can't hit a ball as far as those guys
those guys absolutely crush it
but you can if you catch one though look
out basically
yeah and it wasn't a blue move yeah and
so other guests
this year tiffany haddish i will
definitely tune into that i find her
hilarious
what's your conversations with tiffany
like on the show
just amazing from from the background
that she came from to where she is now
and being one of time magazines
you know 100 most influential people
she's
man you feel her charisma rich when you
meet her is
is something that's like magnetic or i
don't know what you call it
but man she can light people up on on
her stand-up stuff and of course
her girls trip broke her out but she's
absolutely on fire
and she's just an amazing person uh so
it was a great day at the office if you
want to call what i do in office
well you have to i guess technically
another guest from this season uh was
just on the show chris brockman my
colleague
across the way bert kreischer is uh what
stone called steve austin
does he take his shirt off in this
episode steve what do you think
i say yes i say absolutely he does
he does and we drink beer and he's so
funny he told so many
uh outlandish hilarious stories i spit
out more beer than i drink
that makes sense to me he is just
out of his mind he truly is out of his
mind
but he is so damn funny you're right
about that he is out of his mind but
but but he's out of his mind in the
right creative way
yeah what kind of i haven't hung out
with him personally so he could truly be
out of his mind
i don't know go and ask the question
chris go ahead yeah steve
what what would the machine wrestling
gimmick look like
bert's alter ego what do you think man
[Laughter]
that's a great question we were in a
swimming pool standing
uh there drinking beer he was wearing
what he was wearing so
uh when you see the episode with bert
that would be the machine
[Laughter]
that's a teaser i love that's very good
before i let you go uh a season one
guest
had a big huge night last night you had
baker mayfield on your show
in season one and he came up with his
first career playoff win
doing for cleveland what cleveland hoped
he would do for them
uh in just his third year of being with
the team
what what did you glean from baker when
you got to meet him
steve i i gleaned that he had a future
i i that i i liked the young man that i
met
he says all the right things he does all
the right things he was never the chosen
one he's worked his tail off to get to
where he is
you know i think he said maybe i'm
paraphrasing but he just needs to let me
play football and focus on football it
seems like that's what he's doing
uh they got a lot of talent over there
baker is
a born leader and i think he's a born
winner and i wish him the best and i'm
proud to have had him on the show
steve thanks for coming on this show
like as always if you ever need me for
anything i know that uh
you know covet hit just as we were going
back and forth about appearing on your
podcast i just love our conversations
and uh so do the fans of this show who
are going to watch you on straight up
steve austin tonight
uh on usa thanks for the call really
appreciate it man
thanks rich and we'll stay in touch and
we'll do that appreciate you you bet
that's steve austin
stone cold right here cool at steve
austin bsr on twitter instagram right
here on the rich eisen show
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here